I'm team everyone I'm team Millennials I
got a bunch of supportive GM's last
night being like don't let the hater
stop you from doing your thing I'm
scared you I agree I just I like to keep
me Millennials for myself I'm selfish
that way well good morning to all of our
Millennials and we some of our viewers
are never alone is we have Gen Z's I
mean a bunch of moms so a bunch of my
respectful young moms old moms grand
moms new moms fresh moms red moms blue
moms soon-to-be mom yes we're all about
one right here
I'm excited for the day me too except
then you're gonna move that chair and
put it in the lazy boy oh my god that is
such a good idea yeah and like I'm
really excited for that day but like
then I have to stop drinking it so like
I'm not that excited yet yeah but then
you'll have that pregnancy glow they
told us I think the pregnancy glow is
just so out drinking no and I also don't
need like to be bigger and sweaty or
like I have enough of that right now I
need to get this under control before I
move forward into taking control of
someone else's life okay that's very
fair
but today's Thursday April 19 it's
chilly to shout out to my twin friends
on original it's her birthday it's also
the anniversary of the day I got my
period
oh wow the very first time what grade
were you in I was in the eighth grade me
too and I'm very a very good time to get
it I agree
at first but you're not last yeah and
honestly Margo was Margo had I think the
worst possible we had moved schools our
parents got divorced so we like moved to
the city and when you started a brand
new school which was like is worried
dramatic which is the worst thing a
child can go through and in the fifth
grade mark on her first day of a new
school in the fifth grade wearing a
skirt I was in fifth grader was in
nursery whatever it was it was [ __ ]
early oh my god who cares my story is
very normal I know I wasn't in eighth
grade I was in the seventh grade and I
was going to soccer practice yeah that
happened I had to go pick up some pads
and like daddy was waiting outside Duane
Reade and I was like don't come in I was
being such a woman you know like do not
come in I will be back but today has
multiple meanings so it's it's the first
time I'm here and it is also my friend
on a Rachel's birthday that's how I
always remember it and it's also the
your sight of our grandfather so like I
always remember I always remember all
three thing and then tomorrow is the
birthday of your son yes oh my god okay
so so weird Theo's birthdays for 2018
but I always laugh because I feel it's
about pop and we're like reaming it's so
high on the u.s. birthday but Theo has a
cavalier friend named Ruby who like
they're so cute and like they always
hang out and it turns out Ruby's
birthday is to the 21st so are they
gonna do a 20-person Ruby's having a
birthday on Sunday so we're just gonna
pretend it's like Theo's party okay good
because I was waiting to make plans
marks I didn't know if he was gonna
throw himself a party
I don't maybe we'll do like a just like
a celebratory Shabbat dinner oh that's
nice where Theo's the star maybe he
could like eat with us at the table
actually we'll be at dinner tomorrow
night
you won't know where will you be there's
a plans you're so busy I am JD I'm so
excited for Theo's first birthday I feel
like he's had a whirlwind of a year yeah
lest we forget
Theo is a Texas boy you know he's a
Texas boy at heart he's come so far in
the big city and I couldn't honestly
just like I couldn't be more proud of
him he's just like Zak was just here
because I exact doesn't feel any kinship
towards him and Zak goes to the bathroom
in the house and Zak is in nephew hater
yeah totally
he'll definitely can like sense it no
totally he's not a good uncle speech and
no he's not hope he's better to your
actual children say oh so like he's just
come so far in the past year and like
it's almost meant to be what you really
missed an opportunity to wear your
period sweater [ __ ]
Mary we great call I hadn't known this
was such a special day to you I'll have
to put it in my planner wait everyone
please comment in the Facebook and you
think James the first time you got your
period I thought maybe anyone had like a
crazy story um I got my period in the
8th grade it was uh it was a cold
January and it was very it was very
normal and it was a right time for me
perfectly you were at remember in the
summer before what shade of red was it
brown okay now your that's the sort of
thing that we talked about on the page
I'm sorry sorry yeah yeah the seven
before Margo gluing on her period at cam
and I slapped her and she didn't know
that there was a thing so she was shook
and that's what you're supposed to do
like Jewish mothers like slap you yeah
when you get your period apparent
means something but I don't think it's
like what they didn't pull in do you
know yeah but like in the shtetl yeah I
remember the day Olivia got her period
she went to the nurse's office and I
happened to be in the nurses up it's
like faking illness she was wearing
white juicy sweatpants she got sent home
a lot of Paris said sixth grade and my
teacher wouldn't let me go to the
bathroom that's abuse that is abuse that
would never happen in today's world
because like you could see no viral
having a period you get a gofundme yeah
the session like BuzzFeed has with
periods and like being embracing your
period this is the thing I'm a FEMINIST
like I think being a woman is amazing
and we [ __ ] deserve equal rights and
the fact that like we don't is [ __ ]
but I will never embrace my period or
likely public about it like the worst
the most public thing I'll do is like
have a tampon like sneaking out of here
because I hide it in my shirt to go to
the bathroom to change it okay you say
that but we just spent five minutes so
total Bentley talking our periods and
you talking about period different
colors of periods you very varied
sweaters kiddo maybe you should apply
for a job at the scene um I'm so good I
here are the list of things I would
rather do than work at that [ __ ] I
would rather get rid of the oh okay
seriously before his first birthday I
don't care how to miss his birthday I
would rather have Theo live something
with someone else okay I would rather
watch the movie Lobster for 24 hours
straight over and over and I would also
rather watch someone find themselves
with a knife than ever work at BuzzFeed
okay okay that's pretty fair here is the
morning toast I'm Claudia a shy girl
with no job I'm Jackie ah hey Jackie O
problems and here are the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast every time we say that I
get so hungry by the way I've been like
an hour old chill like I used to not eat
before and I was fine like now I'm not
okay I'm [ __ ] starving used to have
like goldfish before him yeah like that
stuff makes you hungry but it just holds
you over during the show start angry I'm
not gonna live here or not premia I
think it's because we've been waking up
really early yeah we gotta stop doing
that yeah okay and then you'll your
hunger won't paint you til after the
shower and we can go what are the five
stories the first story which I love
it's a little weenie but josh groban and
sara bareilles to host the 2018 Tony
Awards that's nice I kind of categorized
Josh Groban in that category of like
Kelly Clarkson pink like doesn't get as
much respect as they shed but is
supremely talented supremely talented
works with David Foster is living the
dream also dated Katy Perry which is so
underrated but I kind of seen them
together he's still with Kat Von D
whatever Hennings no no that's the eye
full you know I shan't follow me on
Instagram so I'm good even though we
like deemed a lot that's been maybe
she's just like her publicist told her
to cut down on Horatio no I think like
when our whole thing went down like I
think she don't wanna be near me cuz
like I'm toxic now that's what I thought
oh you think it was I mean it happened
during that time which is like not cool
come on this is so that's so interesting
I wish you couldn't know I know I
checked a lot of like the famous
personas who like followed me to see if
anyone follow me because they thought it
was like mean and for the most part
nobody wavered so a joy shouldn't follow
me but I don't know if that was before I
think it was before I don't see her as
being a fan of your work I don't see us
like getting along at all like not what
so much about you by accident no 100%
yeah I would have me and Kat Von D
Demmings whatever her name is we and we
DM talk about scrunchies and she gave me
a lot of insight I'm like how to sleep
with a blowout so whatever if it's good
enough for Josh Groban it's good enough
for you guys no love lost over kat
dennings that show sucks
for sure what occult two Broke Girls
yeah whatever it's a story about us
I don't know I just want to see Josh
Groban happy and like with someone who
has an equally good personality cuz I'm
pretty sure he's really funny also like
little-known fact about me I think I'm
Josh Groban's like a number-one fan I
think you are to women who are below 30
and of women like we've known about his
work like since the ages since the
inception before he started singing
English songs we used to listen to hear
I am like okay Anna we used to listen I
know other words an Italian Italian tiny
son Kelly coos no we like we were so
cultured growing up listening to just
grab it when Josh Groban came out like
American music it was good too but like
I enjoyed HNO much more like you raise
me up doesn't even do it for me no I
you're so wrong it's like it's good but
that's what everyone knows him for but
it's not my favorite Josh great song you
if you are willing to like take a chance
on some unknown Steen's like listen to
some Josh Groban today I really don't
think he'll be disappointed if you take
baths I highly suggest a chata he did an
album of covers you did an album of
covers of Broadway shows and there's one
that he did with Kelly Clarkson and it's
fantastic pink there too
no I think she was a producer with David
Foster the dream team right so David
Fletcher discovered Josh Groban he
discovered Celine Dion he's just so he's
an eye for that do you want to know an
interesting fact if you want to know how
he discovered Josh Groban you needed
someone to fill in in the studio to sing
on drea Bocelli stuff that had that sort
of tone but just as like a stand-in like
a what's it called a an understudy right
and then he like discovered like a scene
that like yeah Josh Groban was a sea
pillar for Andre Hotel II and that's
where he is in my heart as well
yeah I'm not gonna bite I kind of like
Josh Groban more than I'd rabbit Ally me
too but I think we're supposed to no I
just no more Josh Groban songs that's
what it is yeah there's one supremely
talented and supremely overly English
where's Andrea Bocelli it's very funny
song like the Andrea Bocelli song like
that they also seems from step rather
stepfather's yeah I mean either makes
you know Andrea Bocelli twice when we
were younger we used to go to Atlantis
like all the time and he had a residency
there there would always be a big shot I
think we didn't really know who he was
like we like knew like some oh my god we
need to go see Josh Groban let's get on
it okay I'll text even faster cuz you do
know that I do have his phone number
it's time to go faster right now no just
abused it and well but can you ask that
Josh Groban's tour schedule yeah yeah
yeah okay and we gotta go to LA so I'd
go to dinner with David Foster him and
Sara Bareilles are hosting the 72 annual
72nd annual Tony Awards which will
arrive from Radio City Music Hall in New
York City on June 10
I [ __ ] hate Sara Bareilles I'm so
sorry I know people love her I don't
love her like what is there to hate so
much and we just don't need a world with
both Sara Bareilles and Colbie Caillat
like there's only room for one of them
and I much prefer Colbie Caillat
music I disagree I think Sara Bareilles
like brings something too and for some
like the musical waitress like pisses me
off I don't know why I like that I don't
know if you guys
know what it is if you don't live in New
York but there's ads for it everywhere
like Sara Bareilles worth the music for
it she's starting it and now there have
like Daedelus talent being rotated and
like Jason Mraz's in and now like I'm
sorry I've no time for wait just ignore
it North Sara Bareilles I'd like she'd
one good song she had a couple love song
what brave gravity oh sorry sorry
actually I take it back
gravity's best song of all time but I
preferred song by Alex and Sierra from
x-factor that I do Sara Bareilles okay
but they wouldn't have sung it if it
weren't for actually another thing about
of gravity was I go to shower songs like
that I really practice my vocal
abilities how's it started okay whenever
whenever I think of a song to sing and I
start like about to sing it for some
reason I always start singing I'm not a
stranger that's the greatest song of all
time how does it start such a good song
[Music]
my right foot is falling asleep anyways
I'm here for this I probably still won't
watch the Tonys because I am Broadway's
least number one fan but I feel like the
Tonys are lit and you know what everyone
should do once they're done watching the
toast and then sharing the toast on
their feet and sharing it with their
friends and following their also job
Jackie oh problems boy was no job pup
with no job Olivia asteroid Margaret
body by snitch hungover and hungry I
think is they should go watch Leah
Michelle's don't rain on my parade cover
at the Tonys where she sings to Beyonce
Beyonce sitting in the front row and she
does it how she did in clichy like walks
from the back of the stadium and like
enters and she's like singing to Beyonce
yeah it's like loving it and jay-z
that the Toni's took creative direction
from Lee Glee was very impactful in so
many fields I think it was a little
ahead of its time cuz like back then we
were still using words like that's okay
like back then we weren't appreciative
of it like no I think he came at the
perfect time because he came at a time
when when we needed to change maybe
maybe get invited it propelled some
change I'd like think I watch it now and
like I learned so much it's really like
an amazing show it is but it got kind of
weird about it no no yeah see it's it I
only consider like real Glee like
Susan's before they all move to New York
yeah I just think like every kid should
[ __ ] first of all just amazing take
learn songs and I learned a lot of songs
like not for my generation like
literally one of my favorite songs is
big bottom fat bottomed girls by Prince
or someone else know what fat bottomed
girls know I know I have a hard time
like separating the characters from the
actors like Michelle is [ __ ]
unbelievable she is always her name's
Rachel yeah what about Naya Rivera she
really distanced herself from commented
on the Kim Kardashian's Instagram with a
negative thought I'm sorry but you're a
mom please so are you with David Spade
or whatever I can't keep up anyways
congratulations to Josh Groban Sara
Bareilles but when we have like a free
minute when we can't think of what to
talk about a yesterday's closing yeah
well here are some things I was talking
with people who Josh Groban should date
because it's such a catch can you write
this down on your little iPad these are
things I want to talk about what I
always forget okay hold on maybe
somebody people have some questions
about the patreon so I just want to
address that one okay patreon Josh
Groban who we should date Josh Groban
girlfriend and then I want to talk a
little bit more about my Caroline show
because of a few tickets to sell and I
need to plug it okay
carob what we would do without this iPad
and just think how much you need fun of
me for it I really want like more like
content in my mouth one of your water
yes I'm like loving being a muggy steam
you know yeah you're mugging out can you
guys hear this ASMR your ASMR it's ASMR
is not pleasing okay ASMR me me watch
over the crunching and whatever it's
amazing it's not amazing okay are you
ready for the next story yes Danielle
Staub is filming a destination wedding
for Real Housewives of New Jersey
there's going to be another wedding by
Bravo and insider told paytrik someone
say the thing else stops upcoming
wedding with Marty Caffrey will be
filmed for Real Housewives of New Jersey
they're getting married May 5th on
Bimini Island and insider said Robert
wuhl cameras will film it Bimini Island
that sounds lit yeah we only reason
might know anything about baby knee is
one because they went terrence yes yes
only reason and they went in about
rapture and that's where Rachel and
Vanessa fought secretly to see it I just
wish they'd release the tape I know
welcome to YouTube for ABC to release
wait
I had something to say that I didn't
talk about unreal on our recap yesterday
of Real Housewives of Beverly Hills is
that Camille got engaged and I thought
that Kyle's reaction was like so genuine
I was like so I was like that is such a
nice reaction well and I got then the
promised reaction was so [ __ ] like
I've hunted every such final it good for
you know there's so much I saw like a
quote card recently that really spokes
me was like the people who always talk
about your past like I don't know I
forget or need not be in your future all
right because like they're trying like
they're don't want good things for yeah
no I agree so I wouldn't tag me and I'm
so poignant and actually thought about
Vanderpump I completely agree so Camille
and I have the same and so I love her
even more I'm really happy for her even
though she brings a tote to the club but
she also brings a good attitude and a
good time so that's all you can actually
looks they replayed the scene of her and
Kelsey getting out of the limo she looks
the exact same
yeah even without Matt I've seen is like
so iconic they go at separate doors
because like they were on different
paths he's so out of control and now
he's put her on that show he could have
an affair and so that he could divorce
her and like leave her but the job which
is kind of nice
he took it and she also got thirty
million dollars it's like she's really
fine but like nobody think about it like
thirty million dollars it's like not
enough for me and forever right and if I
rebel that she was living with two kids
and associate was like solely
responsible more than two kids I think
whatever and she's like four but she I
guess she get much she gets child
support too
because the kids are young no well are
they oh yeah they're like all underage
money yes and they they can't work in
certain country yeah and they're not me
they're NotI LaBelle's I mean till I
lamellae even is no Gigi Hadid I know
but like I kind of like to either doubt
more than I like Gigi I didn't well
that's because at this stage Gigi was
that when she was at Delilah's stage we
loved her more than anyone in the hotel
doesn't become overexposed like she
remember like I was obsessed with Gigi
like before anyone else was I was
obsessed with Gigi like I said she was
eating almonds like I used to tweet
pictures of her like every single day
just like I was like a Gigi Hadid fan
account and then like when she got
famous we were like happy for her and
then she became like everywhere and
everything and like we were so over it
but like I was like really Gigi Hadid
like first fan when she was doing that
guest photo shoot and she was like on
the horse and like Yolanda she's the
best body ever and now she waits like 40
pounds less it's crazy it's like back
then I thought she was a skinny its
prettiest girl live and like the
vectored she looks and nothing like that
girl like makes me sad I understand
an insider also told us back in February
that stab and Caffrey were planning to
tie the knot over the summer when her
daughters Christine and Gillian were off
from school as they'll serve as her
bridesmaids including LaGuerta who broke
that news on our show the couple was
thinking of a tropical location like st.
Thomas at the time another source hinted
that they pushed the wedding up for the
show so she could demand a bigger
paycheck next season whose doub film
their engagement for the show back in
May but appeared on the series in a
friend capacity um yeah and I wonder if
like Bravo will foot any of the bill I
don't think so but why Neal came on our
show
she told us backstage like she was
initially like kind of pissed that they
made her friend of housewife but that in
the end it really ended up working out
and so this time I hope they give her
the respect that she deserves
I think they well because whether
Instagram she posted something that made
it seem like they they will and also see
he's out so that leaves an open spot
they carry in Jersey not apples it's not
peaches not diamonds maybe not some
cities don't carry anything oh you're
right what I carry in Orange County
oranges Oh duh in Texas they carry stars
I think looks cute in Atlanta I think
they carry peaches yeah well that makes
sense New York they carry apples
um what they carry Miami a son I don't
know that's it does anyone know the I
want to leave a comment drop a comment
yeah drop a comment okay I feel bad that
there's no expanding on that story
no yeah I'm excited for her I just have
some New Jersey like doesn't do it for
me anymore pull me in the way the other
franchises do I feel like I've really
matured and like the sense that when
housewives were like at his peak I was
in high school and I was like a big New
Jersey Teresa flip the table big New
York fan like dabbled in Beverly Hills
Dina wants Elena but my taste in
Housewives franchises has really evolved
where like Atlanta it's like almost my
number one and I can't be bothered with
New Jersey I just really cuz that man is
your number one yeah you didn't even
watch everything is it well I didn't
watch this most recent episode yet Oh at
a much New York you know it's so good
well honestly whatever is on is usually
my number one but just in terms of like
taking a step back looking at it from an
aerial view like what gave me the most
to work with this franchise on and off
screen and that was my house was in
Atlanta for me it's adjustables yeah I
don't follow anyone from Atlanta uh I
don't know if I felt okay my fellow
Brielle I fell oh Kim Nene Brio a nice
fella Phaedra but she needs justice
I met Frasier and I loved her you know
who makes me love Phaedra the points guy
two points I'd the points guys the best
friends with a draw
yeah and she's just like she was great
yeah she was so nice and coming on and
she's like my height so I just
appreciate people we're short because we
just see the world from a different view
yeah anyways this next story is like sad
and like conflicting Abby Lee Miller has
been diagnosed with non-hodgkins
lymphoma doctor says one day after going
emergency surgery for what was initially
thought to be a spinal infection Abby
Lee Miller has been premarital
preliminary diagnosed with non-hodgkins
lymphoma cancer that develops in the
lymphatic system people confirms it was
not an infection it was a type of
non-hodgkin's lymphoma it's a type of
cancer we're getting and I ecologist
involved and we have to figure out what
the next steps are as far as
chemotherapy or radiation or more spine
surgery depending on the tumor type
depending on the sensitivity of the
tumor it just depends the type but I
feel more than yes she will undergo
chemotherapy or radiation that's really
sad and also like now that anything
about it so that she went to jail so
obviously like people are up in her but
like she wouldn't take jail for like a
non violent crime like she don't axis a
victimless crime it's like she the only
person that she harmed it's like the
government which is like they needed it
yeah like what so she could give them
more money for taxes so they could not
do anything and my kids could you go on
the road like the joke about kids
jiggling on the FDR is so buddy but it
wouldn't check on the after because
that's actually paint when I was meeting
you the other day downtown we had to
drive at a glacial pace because the
roads are unpaved it's mean the city is
not safe for big breasted women it's not
and you know we should start a party the
the bbw party that's a whole big big
big-breasted women and just like the
coalition needs to get air conditioning
on the subway because I get under boob
sweat on the subway we need to invest in
paved roads and there's just other
things that is a big breasted woman like
New York is not providing for me
and also like the tampon tax but the
more I think
okay so Martin my friend Margo sister
Abigail he's like really into all this
stuff and she's like mentioned it once
when we were like out in the Hamptons
and she was like you have to pay taxes
on tampons I'm like well of course you
do and then I'm like we get that's
[ __ ] up right like what do you want me
to believe in the streets right but no
you had it what's the thing that men
need like every month that they have to
pay for
women don't because you can't say razors
because women need razors right bro
right champale like yeah totally and
that the more thought about unlike she's
right this is [ __ ] no it's [ __ ]
like Entenmann's already so expensive as
and when it comes to tampons like I need
the Gucci of tampons like I will not I
will not stand for cardboard applicators
or let alone no applicators
that's insane when I was in Israel my
first time I bought to him and I didn't
know what and they bought new Peter
tampons and I had no clue what I didn't
use this [ __ ] anything I couldn't I
couldn't use them it was so sad wow this
episode is really like way back to
wheeler which timmons you use tip export
the best gentle guide sport is the best
you know I couldn't play less sports and
I couldn't need anything like it exports
commercials are the best light period
filled episode no I know but you know
like we're dispelling myths around
menstruation yeah I hope we have a lot
of male viewers today I think education
is power pleat x-gen book line you guys
shift into glide that's the commercial
and then also we were talking about the
other day how apparently ten months have
so many like chemicals well because we
were in the bathroom here and there's a
Lola tampon and I worked with Lola once
and like I learned so much that like
literally tampons made and like regular
like any company you've ever heard of
like he's filled with chemicals and make
sense cuz like some of them are scented
and right it was just so scared to be
putting like stuff in my in your I know
so like I'm and then my friend Rachel
she was like yeah use Lola Mike look II
do she's like yeah let you know and
she's like not like that she's not like
earthy she's like yeah why do you want
to put all those chemicals up you every
time I'm like you're right so simple so
simple okay so maybe you'll switch I
think we should there's no reason not to
and yeah Margo our sister used to wear /
still kind of works at the company that
started Lola yeah
so it's medicine free tampons or you
just yeah tampons are so expensive and
but they I never had them that's what
brought us to the root of this
conversation but back to Abby Lee Miller
she's been through so much a victimless
crime I totally agree and like justice
or Maddie Ziegler
you know actually
Tyler Henry medium last night shut up I
paused it to take a phone call and of
course my YouTube TV like Jackie's over
YouTube too because last night was the
last draw and Zack of Greece with me
because he's been standing you to TV and
last night they don't have report they
don't have CW and that was it
like I think Zack actually likes
Riverdale more yeah than I do so we were
really upset and then we looked at the
package and this is what's so deceptive
it says that they have CW but really
they just have a CW app yeah that's such
[ __ ] and honestly YouTube like I
expected more from you I didn't expect
deception
wait back to Maddie Ziegler I'm not one
to talk the [ __ ] about a minor so I
won't but I did read alot about her yeah
but the blonde was ambiguous and all it
said was that she has a huge seeker
coming out didn't say what it was but
like it could ruin her career supposed
to make her career right also Titus
Burgess love was on hollywood medium and
every time I was on something yeah and
so was Jax but of course I didn't
actually get to see any ones reading
this ever Titus and every time I see him
and something makes it so clear like
this isn't the first time I felt this
that he's really not Titus Andronicus
okay I completely agree I met him like
he doesn't like singing pinot noir okay
ready
I met him at my old job at a company
whose name we shall never utter on the
show and they have a lot of celebrity
talent coming in and my job was to like
this was like way back in the day when I
was still in college my job was like to
take pictures get like social media
content of the celebrities like at the
company so obviously I was so excited to
meet I descend Ramadan and I was like
please sing Pinot Noir he could not have
been meaner and he was like no he's like
that's not my thing I'm like what so
what is your thing like of course it's
their thing he was not down he's not
dropping on and like that's a hard pill
to swallow especially because he goes by
the same name like Miley Cyrus and Miley
Stewart we're one of them I just I maybe
it's me as a consumer but I have a
really hard time like separating people
from their characters I'm like I only
like depends on the character right like
there are some people like I mean I was
gonna use John Brown and see what made
me always think her of her is Rachel but
she's just like ambiguous woman in a
movie totally but like David Schwimmer
it's like the anti Ross but just so
upsetting cuz like Ross is my favorite
character that is really I got a lot of
[ __ ] the other tenants are every saying
Russell's my favorite character and I
got into a fight in our friends group
which is we have a you know as our
morning show starts being a big group
and then we have like subsets of the
group's for people who like Stan
different things and I made one for
friends because I
I always have questions and thoughts
about friends and someone was like who's
your favorite character and I was like
Ross and like I got so much [ __ ] for and
I'm like are you guys nuts I look at him
it as a perspective first of all he's a
total catch Jewish guy has PhD and like
only wants to get married and I love a
woman and like no one will let him you
know he's the best and I would literally
fight anyone who disagrees with me
oh and resource Monica um Monica
yeah because like I was just thinking
like every character has like an iconic
line and iconic phrase I literally could
not think of one for Monica I still can
that's really the suicide also who's
different from their character but like
in kind of a good way Emilia Clarke and
Daenerys she is like the most energetic
bubbly like youthful vibrant person
there's like stoned old but it's good
because I really feel like I'm watching
it I don't feel like when I see Amelia
I'm seeing Daenerys but we also don't
get exposed to Amelia a lot she's not
like friendly like a social media
friendly
she is social media feminine she yeah in
serum is so weird that I actually don't
follow it oh yeah it's like very um
working quirky she's a quirky yeah I
hope nobody ever ever ever uses very
quirky to describe me or my social media
it's like I think the worst part you
know but I think of quirky when I think
of quirky literally what comes to mind
is Quinn from Zoey 101 Oh Zoey Deschanel
oh that - 500 days of summer and that
girl from Zoey 101 quite intranasal
summer was the worst movie I ever saw
until I saw a boyhood and then the
lobster but no no 500 summer he's like
not a bad maybe like if it's on I watch
it I'm just so confused by it because
did it turn out that she was mentally
ill or she was just weird I think I fell
asleep
also people are saying Monica's iconic
line is I know oh no no it's not good
she says like that like okay just be
like you're the best you're the best
oh no it's like exactly by the jacket as
much Fred so like you guys know I don't
but um but Alec follows my favorite
character yeah okay this next story I
read it yesterday I was like I hope it's
part of our Fast Five
Charlize Theron gained 50 pounds by
eating mac and cheese at 2:00 a.m. okay
so I read this - and I was confused hear
me out hear me out
Shirley sarin put on a whopping 50
pounds to play overwhelmed mother
Marlowe in her new film Tully I wanted
to feel what this woman felt and I think
that was a way for me to get closer to
her and into that mindset she told
Entertainment Tonight you know it was a
huge
to me I got hit in the face pretty hard
with depression yeah for the first time
in my life I was eating so much
processed foods and I drank way too much
sugar I was not that fun to be around
I was news as described Theron 42 would
eat around the clock just to keep the
weight on like all of a sudden you're
just done eating that amount and then it
becomes a job she said after confessing
to eating in and out for breakfast I
remember having to set my alarm in the
middle of the night in order to just
maintain the weight she goes into
gluttonous detail a she [ __ ] I would
literally wake up at 2:00 in the morning
and I'd have a cup of cold mac and
cheese just next to me the Oscar winner
shared I would wake up and I would just
eat it I was just like shoving in my
throat it's hard to maintain that weight
this is how you know this person is a
celebrity it is not hard to gain weight
and it's certainly not a full-time job
all you need to do is have like three
unhealthy meals a day and then like a
bunch of snacks so give me to wake up
and eat like that is so stupid do you
know how many people gain weight on the
Reg just in the 12 hours that they're
awake that is so stupid that's how long
you wait for like say you wake up
transferred for 12 hours and then no you
wake up like around 8 or 9 you go to bed
around like 11 this is like 15 hours
yeah whatever
I'm saying it's like she's obviously
been in the Hollywood bubble too much
and like it hasn't been eating like one
piece of celery per day because like she
thinks that in order to gain 50 pounds
you have to be like around-the-clock
eating like in your sleep like [ __ ] are
you kidding like I'll show you I get 50
pounds like the last three months no I
literally gained 50 pounds don't you
know but like but like I actually gained
500 pounds like it's not that hard I'll
show you maybe you should have played
the woman someone in the comment said
something sorry I just want to go back
to the friends thing Ross's physical
comedy is like unparalleled like the
physicality the physicality like he's
hilarious and he's like verbiage is
funny but the way he like reacts
physically is what makes him such a
great character thank you so much for
saying that I put my finger on it
I'm glad blast worried and this will
lead us into a real housewives of new
york recap even though cloudy didn't
watch like you really didn't miss
anything on there I know things that I
think I'll even understand okay yeah
Bethenny Frankel has broken her silence
on her fall out with BFF Cara rats well
is there a really bad blood between the
skinny girl on the princess
Bethenny Frankel says I feel like that's
like the way they say it and Princess
Diaries yeah the princess no wait I give
you oh my god I just drank so much water
I never told ah so once you get to make
over they have
pictures of yeah and now he stalks that
movies good two and three were horrible
not horrible not horrible
bethenny frankel finally addressed her
rumored feud with her bestie Real
Housewives of New York City co-star
Conrad's well there's no fallout between
Carroll and myself I really love Carroll
Bethenny recently told Australia is the
fix oh that's how you know it's real
most of my friends my best friends I'd
have four thirty years my best friends
so I'm a really tight-knit group and
meeting any new people as always I don't
want to say risky but it's not the same
deepened dimension for us as friends
that you'd have your whole life it's not
the same yeah also this isn't really
making sense and creating friendships
under these circumstances on the reality
show with so many people around if you
have any sort of slight shift
everybody's well what happen and that
happened and so everyone's involved
there are too many cooks boiling the
broth but I love Carole and I love being
on the show with her and it's been a
great experience
no there's bored of that than that it
has a lot to do with the charity but
definitely didn't support her charity
when she was running a marathon and
carolton support her charity would
choose saving the world has a lot to do
with Tinsley I believe okay so if you
did happen on that same episode okay
tell me the one thing that I wrote down
saying needed to remember to tell you so
Mona pulls up to her Hamptons house she
has a designer she's meeting an artist
there um who's like gonna give her some
artwork for her house she's late they're
already in her driveway whatever she's
so rude she gets into the house she has
the artists take her bags out of the car
and bring them into the house oh do you
mind just bring those upstairs they get
upstairs then she's showing them around
she said oh I got this new furniture do
you mind just putting it she has the
artist as moving men they're carrying
chairs they're putting away wires for
the disso room oh my god it was out of
control she does that also when they
went to UM Aspen and they went skiing
and she got like the hot instructor and
she had him come sit at a price ski and
like get her drinks I felt so bad and
when they went to Mexico she had that
housekeeper Ramona bring her tea like
every morning at 9:00 a.m. like it's so
rude and I think my biggest pet peeve is
like when people are rude to other
people like in the service industry like
it's so [ __ ] demeaning it's like I
can't hang out with Peter but these
purple people weren't even in the
service industry like well renowned
artists carry her Ottomans upstairs now
it's away with that like it pisses me
off
yeah but she's also an older woman so
like you have to think of it it's not
Ramona but like a sixty plus year old
woman like if you have a little old lady
and you go to her house and she asked
you to help move around some things like
you wouldn't feel so bad yes that's true
but she's not my little old lady like
but she 61 like that's not young she
looked so good in this episode really
she's her hair looks so good she I don't
she is like Benjamin Button she's been
looking fantastic and she behaved well
and it was a good episode ago her
Dorinda was out of control well she gets
into a fight with Sonja because like
Sonja's talking about how she's been
through so much and Jordan was like
we're so sick of hearing about how you
got divorced fifteen years ago like I
buried my husband and so what her like
so he's kind of equated like herd of
bushes are like I don't like it was they
were brunching and like there was maybe
like I'm a most I'm the table
I don't really felt that way okay and
then also what was interesting is
Bethenny Carole intensely go out for
brunch in the Hamptons Carole is not
staying about these house Beth Carolyn
tensely got a hotel room we just stay at
Bethenny's like her daughters if she
said she has a full house with her
daughter I'm probably a day so shy day
so shy day and they go to brunch and
like it's like Carolyn Tinsley showed up
together cuz they're staying together
Bethenny showed up like a minute later
and Bethenny approaches the table in the
calendar they don't stop their
conversation like don't even look up at
Bethenny like Bethenny it's so weird
they're like being rude also Bethenny's
really sensitive yeah like she showed up
to her own birthday dinner like 12
minutes late and no one was there yet
and she's like sitting there like being
a weenie like it's not that everyone's
30 minutes late it's like you're filming
print up new yeah there's others
laughter peace isn't like it's not like
no one cared to show up to your birthday
I didn't acknowledge the fact that
they're late it seems as on all of these
shows like everyone's late and that's
just a function of like they're filming
a TV show that easy to just get out the
door I agree
someone tweeted something at me look
really insightful about Dorinda in the
sense that like they paralleled her
behavior to Brandi Glanville where like
she would get drunk and say like below
the belt like crazy rude things and
people like don't acknowledge it as much
as they did Brandi like Brandi was like
hmm but like I guess betraying his
delivery is just like a little better
and she's like a little classier but she
really does like go below the belt a
loss she doesn't go as below as Brandi
no Britta forcing that during this said
to someone I don't know your vagina's
like the Holland Tunnel right that is so
crazy
that's you like you just don't think of
is that crazy cuz coming here and
housewives are like a little bit more
like peaceful than brandy I don't know
and like Dorinda is like older than
brandy and I feel like she a little bit
has the right to say those things where
he's just like she comes out yeah and
she's like a young girl who uses the
c-word and turn the doesn't x-men until
she feels attacked yeah
wears like brandy just like but drin
does also like paranoid and I was always
feeling attacked I think especially I
feel like when she drinks but so do we
all
yes so do we all yeah imagine how like
you would be drunk and I would never if
I was a housewife which I'm working on
becoming I would never ever ever ever
ever ever drink but then you would be a
weiner okay you probably wouldn't last
very long because you have to keep it in
drink
really is that what you've been doing so
hungry are you a big drinker no I'm a
real drinker Glenn Jukes I didn't watch
Riverdale but neither did you so we will
recap that in another time but Margo
called me after she watched and she was
shook was it the carry up so she said it
was so weird a weird mm-hmm [ __ ] I know
but maybe maybe will like it cuz we're
like more mature more tape maybe as like
more art yeah like tasteful yeah and
that's like we're just kind of sort of
the art so can we go back to the list of
things we talked about us before we got
into like all of our self-promotion
let's talk about Josh Groban and who he
should date okay so Josh Groban is like
I would say in his late early 30s mid
mid late 30s I don't know in the 30s um
I thought calves on dennings was weird I
didn't think it was a good pairing they
just I don't see them together he's
really into like artistry whatever he's
really into no he's very very funny you
have to think of okay anyway
a funny guy with a funny bone who's who
are the single females easy honestly
Emilia Clarke because she did a technic
farlan he's also a funny guy you know
she has a funny bone yeah he's very
handsome Josh Groban he's but he's also
like an artist she's very much a part of
like her artist her craft
emilia clark ten that's a really good
one and he definitely watched his game
of thrones
completely he's been doubly like a fan
of hers yeah they've definitely met they
definitely liked and it heavily
appreciates like a real like of woman's
body like she has like a feminine body
do you know any me yeah no they've
definitely made out totally I can't
leave we just paired that oh my goodness
yeah I'll tweet that the other night at
bed Josh Groban was saying
was telling me how he wants to put his
head between your tents okay patreon
what questions you know people are
asking when it's gonna start so I think
when you subscribe I'm 90% sure your
payment starts on the first day of every
month so our first episode is gonna come
out on the first of every of this month
and then we'll start by the May 1st and
then you'll get five episodes that month
people were like is it audio is it video
so here's the thing every up every month
you will get five extra podcast episodes
audio only in addition to that we're
gonna there's gonna be other stuff
there's gonna be video content there's
gonna be photos maybe even some blog
content but that'll vary every month the
five podcast episodes will be constant
and the last thing I want to talk about
is my Caroline show because
unfortunately all the general admission
tickets are sold out so it's just too
bad for you if you didn't get one but
there are a couple VIP tickets left and
then I'm like you know what they're kind
of expensive I should make it worth
everyone's while so once they sell out
which hopefully they do if you want to
buy a ticket May 10th or 11th I'm doing
two shows each night and early and delay
ciao it's gonna be such a good time
VIP ticket gets you I think better
seating and definitely like some time
afterwards so I can you know take a pic
with me but I'm doing a thing where if
you buy a VIP ticket if you've already
bought one or if you're going to buy one
you're automatically entered into this
contest I'm doing and this condescend
doing as they say where I pick ten
people which is kind of a lot and if you
were chosen you'll get the following one
you'll be able to come to a taping of
the toast which will be so let second
and you will get to a boozy brunch with
Ben and I so Ben and I are taking all 10
people out for a boozy brunch on me
where do you think you're gonna go I
think the way there I feel like that's a
good place oh man and then I just kept -
oh I was just there so tea so taste what
a great tuna poke okay maybe I'll use
upstairs like private room okay then
you're so also gonna get a swag bag but
that's wag that will include are some of
my favorite things including beauty
products and exclusive toast merch which
is on its way to you but these people
are gonna get it first and for free some
it'll be over a hundred fifty dollars
worth so really suggest you buying it
and crunches on you yes I meant the swag
bag oh okay there's way more than 150
dollar value oh wow you're just giving
it away now do you wouldn't consult with
me
no I'm trying other beauty products too
Oh some of my favorite things like I
will say what's your favorite thing it
varies like this this week I would say
it's the what wax up
if it highlighted really yeah I remember
you sound like a nice I know you came
out but I don't think we like knew how
to use highlighter and I feel like if it
was very like pigmented if we put it
anywhere it would have been like so much
okay that's the thing too did you know
that it's double-sided yeah it has the
brush side in the highlights I thought
the omen said was the brush side and I
was literally twisting and twisting
interesting for saying that's why it
never came out in high school I was
using the wrong side interesting okay
right now right now and like oh like
this year this year it's probably my
tart drink of h2o serum it is so it's
already using it and now I use it like
right after I wake up and then I make my
coffee do my hair so by the time I sit
down to knock it in its I do it and then
I put my face on their air conditioner
so it like dries it's so good it's good
and even if you do your makeup right
after it's still it doesn't get wipe off
with your else you use it as like a
nighttime moisturizer it's just so
hydrating I like something a little bit
more creamy to a nice time we show they
don't take old lady moisturizer there's
just nothing better um so I think that's
it everyone
what a great show I feel like if you are
trying to get one of your friends or one
of your colleagues to watch the show I
would show them today I would show them
today's show because like this was
premium content and this is pretty much
what you can expect from us every every
day and they don't see any comments
about audio issues so thank the Lord
thank the Lord if they were not if you
are not make sure you are subscribed to
our podcast app because that's where we
will be every day in addition to youtube
you can go ahead and subscribe and like
our facebook page also follow us on
instagram for a major premium content
yesterday I worked maybe four hours on
recreating the back and it came out okay
anyone came out what did people say on
Instagram you posted it did they like it
um yeah they liked it okay it was good
yeah definitely felt some interim for
premium content also jackieo problems go
to a job well have another job pop new
job if you want to follow up up with her
job and wish him a happy birthday
tomorrow I feel like it would mean a lot
of time oh my god Ben was making a funny
joke maybe his official portrait
photographer should come over to take
some birthday photos of him just like
girls we had something so funny because
you know how you always talk about the
old like he's a person like what
Cynthia's calendar today yeah Ben was
making the funniest jokes last night
about it was so sad how probably Theo
can't come to my show because like he
can't afford it because he doesn't
[Laughter]
person maybe for his birthday he could
cameo on the toast done okay we're gonna
and tomorrow's Friday so like he can
definitely come in late Joe I just want
to really be cool you know gonna be all
uncool maybe like take him for a walk
for ya but we can take him for a walk
around here yeah but like how early I
try to wake up tomorrow I don't know
even making up really early anyway you
guys thank you so much for tuning in
that's all we got for you we will see
you tomorrow we'll see you tomorrow have
a wonderful day we're so close to the
weekend you guys like I can smell it
south of we did